now maybe these questions don't deserve
their own subheading okay
they're just the same as they were
before making a definite integral just
means we're adding
boundaries that's all okay but being
that we're adding more things into this
that means that not only are these in x
right
um this is kind of yeah well at the
moment
this is all in terms of x's right so
this is shorthand
um i've actually not written some of the
things on there remember
integral notation right it's it's
precursor is sigma notation
right now sigma notation is a little
more explicit you know if you have
something like say
sum of n squared right they'll start off
by saying you know
n equals one up to five okay so they've
gone ahead and said i mean even this is
shorthand for
n equals one is your first value and n
equals five is your last one
okay now riemann was like well look i
only got one variable here i'm not
interested in
you know so i'm just going to leave off
the variable altogether but really it's
shorthand 4
i'm going to begin at x equals 0 and i'm
going to
end at x equals 1. now just as we're
doing these first few examples it might
be worth it for you to write that down
just to make it explicit so you don't
confuse
variables okay now if i didn't have
boundaries there
okay just think about it as a regular
indefinite integral
what substitution would you make
u equals
okay so my derivative here of this
substitution i've chosen
is good
okay so i've got my d u
now at this point you've got two choices
you can notice that this is minus two x
dx
and i don't have a minus two here right
so i could slap a minus two in front
there right so it matches here
and then out the front i guess i'd have
to put a minus half to compensate so i
haven't really changed anything
alternatively you can come over here and
you can say well what i want
is x dx so how do i adjust this in order
to
account for that well i'm just going to
put the same minus half that i want to
put out the front
i'll put it here instead it's the same
right so whichever you want
um whichever works best can get great
that's fine okay
now this is good i've got my x dx that
i'm going to sub out i've got my one
minus x squared that i'm going to sub
out but i now have to account for these
boundaries
okay so here's a standard way of doing
it i'm gonna have
i've got two x boundaries so i'm gonna
have two u boundaries and it's vitally
important you don't mix them up okay
so i tend to draw myself a little table
okay
so i've got values for x and values for
u
right now at the moment i'm going from
zero to one
okay zero to one so how do i work out
the values for you that correspond to
these wells
very simply yeah i'll take these x
values
and i'll pop them into my definition for
what u is okay
now don't shortcut this because it's
sorry can we draw this one
you mean this yeah yeah absolutely
yeah yeah i'm i i put this all off on
the side and in a different color
just so that i don't confuse my working
but it is all my working
like i would present this all the time
straight through
not off to the side oh i don't think
there's anything wrong with doing off to
the side
because really what we're doing is it is
peripheral work
this is making ready for the actual
process of integration
okay so now
when x equals one what happens to you
well u is equal to one minus one
squared that's zero okay so
one this boundary corresponds to zero
here
okay similarly when x equals
zero right u equals 1 minus
0 squared that's 1. now this is an
unusual situation
you know it doesn't usually just do this
they it just happened that this is the
function we chose okay
but the critically important thing you
get
is that these are non-negotiable okay
this one corresponds to this zero
and this zero to this one and you can't
just flip them because you decide well
that's weird that i'm going from one to
zero
okay we know what this means right as an
integral it means
you're going backwards okay or it's like
the same as putting a minus sign out the
front which i'm going to use in a second
but please don't mix them up that's what
the table is useful for
getting the fact that they correspond to
each other
okay i've fixed up my function i've
fixed up my variable now fixed up the
boundaries
now i can substitute okay so let's come
over here
and just like before even though we
usually don't write it i'm just going to
make explicit what the boundaries are
they're not boundaries in x they're
boundaries in u
so i'm going to start one and go to the
left to zero can you write that
right u equals one so that's just one
okay now i'm just writing it now
just this is the first time we've done a
definite integral with substitution
you're going to get pretty sick of doing
it pretty quickly in fact the next slide
i'm just going to go one to zero okay
but um i think it's helpful here so that
you can see the change
especially when these numbers it's a
classic error
to just forget to change the boundaries
okay and you'll get a totally sensible
answer at the end it doesn't look wrong
and you'll go and check through and
you're working is fine you've integrated
it properly
you just you don't you've missed the
step entirely
right now i had x dx being equal to
minus a half d
u so i'll slap that in there
and the square root of u
okay now i'll get rid of my um my u
equals okay and i'll write it
in a more standard order now i am i
don't like really
having my boundaries backwards and i can
change that
okay it's really easy to change because
i've got a minus sign here right
so seeing as i've got it's kind of like
a double negative if you like i might as
well get rid of one of them
so i'm going to now switch it around
back to
the right order the ordinary order and
i've got a half
mu to the power of a half is that okay
great everything's easier to integrate
when it's an index form
okay okay i think i've done enough
setting up and tidying up what i do here
power goes up i should put my half out
the front
power goes up and then i divide by the
power all right
zero to one okay yep question how did
the
chain switch around um you mean the
boundaries here
yep so what i did was uh at the same
time as switching the boundaries
i also eliminated this negative sign
okay so if you remember back to the
properties of the definite integral
that this integral if you just go
forwards going backwards is just like
putting a minus sign out the front
if i go from b to a
okay good question yeah no
yes it will cancel that's exactly right
but it's um it's a double negative so
i'll get a double negative when i
evaluate my my integral out and i just
i just want to avoid double negatives um
just like i said before you know
how there are all these little numerical
errors that creep in this is one of them
that creeps in
you know um you'll have a something like
this
when you're sorry that's a b
when you're doing this step right
suppose f is something simple like i
don't know
x squared minus 2x
okay so in this case what you're going
to get is b squared minus
2b minus a squared minus
2 a right just a straight substitution
yeah
but a common error to make is when
you're getting rid of the brackets or if
you don't write the brackets in the
first place
you just go yeah minus a squared that's
negative yeah no problems
okay and you miss the double negative we
do it all the time okay
so of course we should be able to get it
but you know it's
we're human so try and reduce the places
that area has been creeping
all right where is our two twos cancel
here so i just get
a third u to the power of three on
two okay and i'm going from zero to one
sorry
so this is a third times one minus a
third
times zero so there is my answer
okay now it's also important to know
from this step
to this step okay we've translated if
you like from x's
into u's right having done that i now
forget that x's ever
existed okay i've gotten rid of them
entirely right
so at this point when i integrate
usually when we have an
indefinite integral you know you get
this and then you say
ah but my original question was in x's
so i better put them back
right that's what we do with indefinite
integrals but i've i've gotten rid of
them completely
you know i'm putting these boundaries in
and i've changed the boundaries
so i don't say we'll use this but
actually you came from here
i better put it back don't put it back
it's gone forever okay
so once you've turned it into use for a
definite integral leave it that way it
will be just denied
yeah that's right that's right if i
change it back
i'm gonna have to if i change it back
i'll have to change the boundaries back
it's like you're sort of
doing it and then i'm doing it on
yourself it's a bit toxologist
okay um but that's all there is to it
okay
so let me just write this in a general
form that was an example
it's a writing over here when
substituting so maybe you want to put
this in a box
okay when substituting
into a definite integral
okay what we start with is
you know a to b of
you know such and such a function
whatever it is okay
what's that going to be equal to well
you've got to change three things right
number one you've got to change the
boundaries how did we do that
um once you've defined it right you
match up the values okay
so in fact this really this u is
actually u of x
like we've substituted a value of x into
that right so
a will turn into u of a
and b will turn into u of b okay so now
it's going to be some number that's
connected to that variable right when
you change this
you're going to get a completely
different function altogether okay
so i can't call it f i'll call it g i
guess and it's not in terms of x's
anymore it's in terms of use
and also you'll need to differentiate so
that you can change the variable so just
one more time right you want to change
boundaries
or bounds you want to change the
function and you want to change
the variable the actually diff i'm sorry
not differentiating but you're actually
integrating
with respect to okay three things make
sure